العالم يتذكر الملكة إليزابيث
الثانية أطول فترة حكم لملك بريطاني
يرن جرس
[موسيقى]
في كنيسة في إحدى الضواحي
بإنجلترا التي
تتدفق من
زعماء العالم الحاليين والسابقين قال الرئيس السابق باراك أوباما
إنه كان مقتبسًا من فترة حكم تحددها
أناقة النعمة والعمل الدؤوب  الأخلاق التي
تتحدى الصعاب والتوقعات الموضوعة
على النساء من جيلها ،
الرئيس السابق بيل كلينتون يكتب اقتباسًا في ضوء
الشمس أو العاصفة كانت مصدرًا
للاستقرار والصفاء والقوة
الرئيس السابق جيمي كارتر الذي يظهر هنا
مع الملكة إليزابيث في
قصر باكنغهام في عام 1977
قائلةً:
والشعور بالواجب كانا
مصدر إلهام
للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب كما
أعرب عن تعازيه قال الرئيس الفرنسي
إيمانويل ماكرون إنه يتذكر
الملكة كصديق مقتبس لفرنسا
وملكة تركت انطباعًا دائمًا
عن بلدها والقرن الذي عاشته والمزيد من
التعازي.  وذكريات من
قادة بريطانيين سابقين رؤساء وزراء سابقين
شاركت تير بوريس جونسون بيانًا
منذ لحظات قائلة إنها بدت
خالدة جدًا ورائعة جدًا لدرجة أنني
أخشى أننا قد توصلنا إلى الاعتقاد مثل
الأطفال بأنها ستستمر للتو ، وقال
توني بلير الذي شغل منصب رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني حتى عام 2007 إن المملكة المتحدة  لم تخسر
ملكًا فحسب ، بل خسرت ملكة
أمتنا
أنت